la cuarentena ha sido muy difícil para
mí porque nos habían quitado
el agua en el problema está en que el
agua la pone
dos veces a la semana entonces es una
corredera y a veces no llega a
suficiente presión y no podemos llenar
todos los potes debemos administrar el
agua como se pueda la removida manguera
la llave
cuando instalen
[Música]
de fuerza para nosotros
esta semana
necesita internet para cualquier tipo de
cosas que necesitas hacer cuál
no me había inscrito en un curso de
dibujo
por whatsapp y ya que no hay internet
tengo que verlo por su teléfono con los
datos móviles porque desde el principio
la cuarentena da el internación
fatal
corrige el internet y no hay
otra vez
y si es uno por netflix no puede
y ya normal en esta pandemia esté
levantada a las 6 de la mañana tenía que
ir a liceos y luego de miércoles y
viernes entre nadal a ustedes o el campo
hola
y haciendo ejercicio
y
marc ante el fútbol no quiero perder la
condición física
de no ocurrir y que lo que sea caer en
ya rápido que sepa de esto y lo primero
que haría sería salir con mi primo por
después volver al liceo y volver a
entrenar